at this altitude I can not flat out for
a half-mile before my hands start
shaking soil for support
now it is I'm a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton so
this episode is brought to you by trunk
club there are two types of men out
there you know who you are guys who love
shopping for clothes that are short on
time category a and those of you who
hate it
category B I am in the latter category
my fashion sense is also probably
somewhere between homeless and confused
with a dash of lazy added in either way
you can take heart and I've used trunk
club now and have found some of my
favorite pieces of clothing that make me
look a lot better than I'd be able to
handle on my own and there are many
reasons for that but you can get
clothing that fits perfectly and looks
amazing without ever stepping into a
store again thanks to trunk club and
they make it very very easy and the
clothing is handpicked by a personal
stylist your own personal stylist all
you have to do is go to trunk club comm
forward slash Tim type in your
measurements share your likes and
dislikes they'll pick your clothes from
more than 80 top brands and ship them
right to your door you keep what you
like you send back what you don't if you
don't like any of it send it all back it
doesn't matter and trunk club is not a
subscription service this is what
appealed to me among many other things I
didn't want to constantly be getting
dinged by things or have to deal with
the headache of constantly getting boxes
it's not a subscription service shipping
is always free
and you have five days to try on the
clothes so a couple points here number
one get started today go to trunk club
comm forward slash Tim try it out you
get premium clothes expert advice no
work no risk that is a winning combo and
I have found some of my favorite
espadrilles shoes from them bright green
I do like to call it green and they
actually work I've had so many
compliments on these shoes and more
people asking where I got them than any
pair of shoes I've ever had and more
shirts I kept ended up keeping about I
would say three quarters in my box which
I did not expect to do so go to trunk
club comm forward slash Tim and check it
out
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for many many
years I absolutely love audiobooks and
they are one of my favorite ways to pass
the time when I travel I'm on the road
all the time and audible allows me to
consume many more books than I possibly
could otherwise I have two audio books
to recommend right off the bat the first
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time it's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman it's
amazing and you won't thank me there are
a few different versions
I like the version that Neal narrates
himself one of the most soothing voices
of all time the second book is
vagabonding by Ralph Hawks Pio tts which
had a huge impact on my life and form
the basis for a lot of what would later
become the 4-hour workweek so go to
audible.com for word slash Tim and you
can choose one of these two books or any
of many many other options that could be
books magazines and much more as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show you can
also access a free 30-day trial just go
to audible.com forward slash to him you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it so turn your travel or
your commute into something more with a
free trial at audible.com forward slash
Tim to start now and get your free
30-day trial
loh ladies and germs this is tim ferriss
who welcome to another episode of the
tim ferriss show where it is my job to
deconstruct world-class performers of
all types whether they are military
strategists super athletes business
icons or anything in between really to
tease out the habits routines favorite
books tips and tricks you can test and
apply in your own life and this episode
was a real treat if you enjoyed my
episodes with Seth Godin Noah Kagan any
episode that really gets into the nitty
gritty details then you are going to
love this one
it is a conversation with soman chainani
and I'll spell that for you som a n CH
AI n pay and I try in English today and
you can find them on Twitter social at
soman chainani and all places he was
introduced to me by Brian compliment
very very accomplished artist
screenwriter producer co-creator of the
hit show billions and a very very long
filmography and when I asked Brian what
I should dig into with some and he said
many things but among others his this
quote is discipline and rigor
carefulness of his approach in all
aspects of life he's an incredible
physical condition he's super careful by
staying at financial security he kept
tutoring after getting a three book deal
he's a detailed planner and an artist of
high order more disciplined and
organized and businesslike than almost
any artist I've met so who a summon well
his debut fiction series the school for
good and evil has sold more than a
million copies well over a million
copies been translated into 25 languages
across six continents been a New York
Times best seller for 130 weeks and will
soon be a film from Universal Pictures
with some and co-writing the screenplay
he's graduate of Harvard University and
Columbia University's MFA film program
after which he began his career as a
screenwriter for film and TV he was
recently named to the out 100 and has
received the $100,000 circle grant and
the Sun Valley writers followership both
for debut writers he's also an
incredible tennis player which you will
dig into and there are a lot of
parallels a lot of transfers between
what we talked about his obsession with
Disney and we cover so much ground I
think you guys will really enjoy this
episode so pay attention get a notebook
ready and please enjoy my conversation
with soman chainani
some and welcome to the show thanks so
much for having me I am sitting here
with a a set of questions and
exploratory bullets and each one of
these could be explored for I would say
an hour or two I would guess so we we
may need a round to at some point but
I'm getting ahead of myself let's start
at the mutual connection that we have
how do you know the incredible Brian
compliment and few people who don't know
that name he is a polymath he is a
writer he co-wrote rounders the illusion
is definitely illusionist he he
co-produced and is co-creator of
billions this new hit show which I'm
absolutely in love with but how do you
know Brian well it started I think
because in my 20s I'd come out of film
school at Columbia and I'd gone straight
to London and I've been working on a
movie over there
for a couple years and that was supposed
to be my sort of hotshot debut and and
all that stuff and it ultimately fell
apart and so I came back to New York
when I was like you know 25 or 26 broke
quarter million dollars in debt from
college in film school and I didn't know
how to make money so you know I didn't
know what to do and luckily a friend
saved me and introduced me to a couple
clients and told me to become an SAT
tutor and so I sort of learned overnight
how to add a tutor and got into that
whole business and it just happened that
Brian's son needed a tutor and so that's
how that's how it started and so you
know I was working with his son and a
bunch of his son's friends as I was
starting to write the first school for
good evil book and so he sort of watched
the entire evolution from hotshot
filmmaker to broke and penniless tutor -
then you know rising from the ashes into
a new career so he knows me better than
anyone my god well he's he is a he
is one of your biggest fans and his the
enthusiasm he's an enthusiastic guy to
begin with yeah but now if we were to
spinal tap that and take it to 11 the
enthusiasm with which he wanted to make
the introduction was of course an
immediate yes then on my part and one
thing he mentioned to me and I wanted to
dig into this in that well first let's
back up and this is going to be a very a
non chronological interview we're going
to jump all over the place because I
have conversations to do but the school
for good and evil how many books are
there in that series right now so
there's three books in the series right
now and then there's a full-color kind
of graphic handbook that's a companion
guide that we offer to like reluctant
readers the kids who hate to read and
will never read novels ever but if they
want to be part of the universe they get
this sort of graphic version of the
world so there's either the three novels
or there's the handbook and then I'm in
the process of writing the fourth one as
we speak and I think they'll probably be
in the end six in the series total just
just also because the movies are going
to start to come out from Universal and
so I wanted to have enough books to
stretch out to match the movies you
didn't want to end up in a in a game of
Thrones situation that I appear at least
once a week I think of that situation
and cannot imagine that just because you
know I get so involved in my work and
like I take it almost too seriously at
times and the idea that you have to
share your secrets of what's going to
happen to somebody who then is going to
put it on TV before you oh my god I'd
kill myself if I couldn't do it so you
are one of the most according to Brian
this is our first conversation you and I
are the most disciplined in rigorous
people he knows in all things and be one
day adjectives adjectives he used was
careful and I wanted to explore that
accept that it might lead us to some
backstory so he said correct me if I'm
wrong that you kept tutoring you kept
doing your tutoring after you got a free
book deal is that true
I can't
after we made the movie deal and the
movie deal like was enough for me to not
have to work for like 15 years you know
so why keep tutoring I just couldn't get
out of my head the idea that art is
something that you should not depend on
I don't like depending on my art for
income because then I start to think in
a mercenary way and so you know I had to
get through my head that it's okay you
know you're making enough now from from
the books and the movies that you you
don't have to confuse them you don't
have to confuse money and art because
the great thing about tutoring was it
took all the pressure off the book even
though I was broke at the time even
though I had nothing going for me it
meant that I could write freely because
at the end of the day my money wasn't
going to come from that book you know
and so I couldn't let go of tutoring I
tutored up until last year it is you
know I went like three or four years
longer than I should have because it
just meant that I had that absolute
freedom in the back of my head that if
you know it all went to pot I still had
tutoring you know should have is a
tricky word right or it's a tricky
contraction because it's I'd like the
separation of church and state that you
described in so much as you not feeling
as though you have to find rent money
through your art even if your art is
compensating you well psychologically
allowing you to compartmentalize that
you don't think about what will sell
best as the primary directive of your
art perhaps where do you grow up I grew
up in in a little island off Miami
called Key Biscayne that is now quite
popular as a resort town now it has a
ritz-carlton it has a Starbucks now it
had matter of the things when I was
growing up it was was basically just you
know beaches and trees when I grow up
and it was very very small but the one
thing that was famous for was tennis
like if you didn't play tennis on Key
Biscayne like you know you weren't part
of the cool crowd and
oh that's a lot of it's a lot of where
players train these days and still so
you know that's sort of where I grew up
and how would you describe your I don't
know what age to pick here mmm
to ten year old self we were were you a
popular kid
let me think no not until high school
and I think it was because I just was a
little confused I think at that age you
know I was the only Indian kid on the
island I grew up on I was one of three
people of color at my high school right
and so you grow up not looking like
anyone else and then once I turned 12
and 13 and I start liking guys instead
of girls that adds another dimension to
the whole thing right and so right also
at the same time I'm basically six-foot
and at that time I was like 110 pounds
Wow cannot put a weight on to say my
life right so all those things it just
felt like I just didn't fit in in any
shape way or form you know and I can I
didn't know what to do when I think it
led me to basically retreat into work
and so you know I became the kid who who
won everything right like they used to
give out subject awards at school every
year to give at 11 on the last day of
school and from seventh grade you know
through like 11th grade I won all 11
every single year so it was basically me
just walking back and forth picking up
trophies because that's sort of what I
did you know I just sort of threw myself
into work and it was only once I got to
the later years of high school eleventh
and twelfth grade that I think I started
to let my real self come out a little
bit you know I just think it broke
through on its own and I think people
started to realize that I actually did
have a sense of humor for all my
workaholic tendencies you know mm-hmm
when did you become openly gay I think
it was my senior year of college and it
wasn't something that
it's so funny because now I watch kids
come out and it's done with such
empowerment and like this kind of
beautiful freedom and if there's all one
thing I'm sort of envious of in the
entire world it's the way that that kids
come out now because when you know we
did it in like the early to mid-2000s
there just wasn't anything out there to
help you you know and so it was just
traumatic having to come out to people
to your parents to your friends every
time you did it it was just trauma you
know and so I think once actually came
out is when everything sort of broke
open and that's when you know like I
think the path I was on up until then I
thought I was going to be in business I
thought I was going to you know be a
consultant or a banker or any of these
things and was only after I came out
that I think my creative self came back
it was almost like that had gone in the
closet too and it and it took time for
both to come out I was talking to a dear
friend of mine
Adam Robinson who's been on the podcast
as a guest before but alongside several
other people and we just did a solo
episode and he battled with depression
for a long time and I've had my own
bouts with depression I'm not saying
these are the same thing but we had a
long discussion about one of the
ingredients being it in authenticity
meaning not following who you are or
opening up to who you are fully as one
of the ingredients in in that particular
breed of of depression so I've thought a
lot about that were you able to be
yourself with your parents at a young
age or did they know you were gay is
that was that a an open secret could you
describe your could you describe your
you're so dynamic with your families you
know my parents are amazing like they're
just both brilliant people and both you
know at the end of the day so
open-minded I I don't know if it was so
much about worrying about disappointing
them as much as at that time in the
world it was just
there were no models of how to do it in
a real way especially in the sort of
like world of Indian families you know
there was nothing so I don't know if it
was them specifically that scared me as
much as the idea I didn't even know what
it would look like I thought if you come
out of the closet you will live this
very small lonely life you know that's
what I thought at the time and you know
what's funny is once I came out once I
became a writer all these things I look
back at that time and think thank God my
life sort of unfolded the way it did
because look if you look at the school
for good evil books there's there's a
hundred and twenty characters right each
has their own story each it's an entire
labyrinth world that I don't keep track
of with notes like I just I know it in
my head
everything's in my head and I think all
of that energy this entire universe of
creativity was trapped right and so no
wonder I was a complete basket case for
her so much of my young life because if
you can't like you know forget the game
thing if you're not actually like
letting out this absolute volcano of
sort of creative energy inside of you
it's going to be rough and so I think
that's sort of one of the missions I
have in life just myself is is whenever
I sense another creative soul who's
who's bottled themselves up I gravitate
towards them and try to find a way to
let them out and that's what the books
are to sort of that the message of the
books in there too is for kids is you
know find your tribe right like don't
don't buy into the matrix of what the
society is telling you a successful
person or a hero has to be find your
tribe what did you major in undergrad
English just because you know when you
go to a school like Harvard you don't
know there's nothing practical right
like a lot of the finance guys will
major in economics or government but
only out of just sort of default because
there isn't anything applicable at that
at a school like Harvard really so you
know in my head I knew I was going to go
into consulting or banking but it didn't
what make what you major dents I figured
might as well major in something that I
actually like which was you know English
I remember and having a an open QA not
too long ago we were talking about well
the question was related to you
entrepreneurship and and I gave a
response and then they interrupted me
said well it's easy for you to say
because you you you're a male I went to
an Ivy League school and and I know know
but I remember thinking to myself the
last thing an Ivy League school does is
prepare you to be an entrepreneur there
so right it prepares you it molds you to
be a very well polished cog in a fancy
machine like consulting or I banging it
but it does not in any way probably if
anything inhibits in many respects
entrepreneurship but that's that could
be a whole separate podcast as but we
have we act at some point do our dump on
Ivy's I have so much to say I almost
want to to tell like put on my forehead
that like if you went to an Ivy I
probably won't date you which is like
the ultimate form of self-loathing where
where did where did film or the fiction
come into the picture you know I think
growing up film was my love like I
always wanted to be in in film in some
capacity I thought that's what I was
going to end up doing the big problem I
thought was that I was not one of these
people craving to direct just for
directing sake right I I didn't have
this burning desire to you know be a
Spielberg or something like that
I wanted to control a vision of a world
right so I already had like a fantasy
streak inside of me I gravitated towards
you know Narnia Lord of the Rings all
the all the Grimm's fairy tales things
like that and so I think ultimately what
I wanted to be able to do only sort of
came into to existence once
JK Rowling wrote Potter because once I
saw Potter I thought oh wait this is
like exact
the kind of brain I have which is create
your own universe control how this
universe is going to to be presented in
media whether it's its books its film
its whatever and I think that's where
school forgiving evil came from at some
level was this you know desire to
somehow bring a universe in my head into
the world in the most fully realized way
possible combining my interest in both
film and literature you know mm-hmm I
have something I can't get out of my
head so I'm going to jump back to tennis
yeah the first thing I was thinking was
at six foot whatever you were 110 pounds
you must have had a really mean surf
that was the first thing I was thinking
and the second is really a selfish or
self-interested question because I have
been considering learning tennis this
year and you've spent an incredible
amount of time tutoring granted doesn't
sound like you were tutoring in tennis
but how would you recommend I learn to
play tennis if I'm going to take it
seriously and what what should I focus
on and what should I spend less time on
maybe things that novices waste a lot of
time on do any thoughts on that it's
such a good question it's funny I'll
tell you I'll tell you how I play to
this day and it might help which is that
you know all year long in New York I
play four or five times a week you know
with different people and it's usually
you know we put matches where we hit or
whatever and then every two months
I go down to Miami to the condo complex
I've lived in since I was a kid and I
play with the coach I've had since I was
a kid I've been playing with him for 25
years and my context for people
listening and you you did not lose a
first-round match for 10 years
gorilla happened was I went ten years
playing tournaments all the time you
know after the this from high school up
until probably my late 20s and never
lost the first match because I always
felt like I paid the entry fee I done so
much work to get there because often the
tournament was in another state or
another country I would not lose it
didn't matter who you put me against I
had this sort of like killer iron will
that would get me
that match and as soon as I started
writing good and evil as soon as I was
putting all my creative energy elsewhere
I think I lost six in a row to pick and
choose where you put your energy right
so I interrupted you telling me how you
how you play them so i go down to miami
and i play with the same coach i'm you
know playing with 25 years he's
basically 70 years old he cannot move so
what he does is he takes a basket of
balls and feeds me to them feeds me them
quite slowly and analyzes my swing on
every single one so it's a hundred
percent about technique 100 percent
about timing it's as basic as it gets
but it's like three or four times a year
he's just training technique and if I
had a kid or had to you know teach
somebody tennis it's get your technique
perfect because the thing about tennis
is it's so unconscious if you try to
consciously think your way through the
strokes or anything like that you're
going to end up in trouble just because
of how fast it ultimately goes it's like
ping-pong so it has to become automatic
it has to become consciously your
technique has to be impeccable and so
one of the things he taught me from an
early age is you know don't rush to the
baseline start at the service line and
get your technique right you know and
then things will flow so I became sort
of a technique obsessive which of course
flows into all the other aspects of my
life because I'm big on technique and
process service line is where you serve
from I know no service line is permitted
is it is that like the line in the
middle of the god here we go alright now
we're at my level thing what define do a
tennis is it rewards it reminds me of
like gymnastics and figure skating where
it rewards attention to detail and is a
reward sort of individualistic obsession
and so it sort of set you're talking
sweet spot of my personality it's just
the one sport I love and I also think
it's a great sport where you know you
could put me up against somebody who is
enormous ly big and you know powerful
and it won't help them you know it's the
sport where power is not going to do all
that much for you ultimate
against somebody who's who fast and we
can see that you know in in the men's
game now with Djokovic and Murray and
all those guys I have next to me
literally five inches from my left thigh
I have the book I'm finishing which is
stories of your life and others by Ted
Chang science fiction compilation of
short stories and then right next to
that is the the next book I was playing
on reading the inner game of tennis by
Timothy gall aw Timothy Galway I don't
know if that's a pronounce his last name
but where do novices waste a lot of time
we're going to get into what makes a
good coach and this is I think going to
take us a few different places but where
should I where should I not spend a lot
of time in the beginning and and that
relates to how should I choose a tennis
coach you know I think one of the things
is when coaches put you against other
kids very early and you're playing
matches very early because they want to
develop your competitive instincts again
I think it's super dunderheaded because
what they don't realize is your
competitive instincts are far stronger
than your technique right so what you'll
end up doing is coming up with this
hatchet job way of playing tennis that
somehow will do the job to win you some
matches but it isn't going to serve you
well in the long run right and with like
memorizing openings and chess versus
learning yeah first principles yes and
like that's how you get to the club and
when you go to the club and you see all
these people with hacking back backhands
or like they slice both the forum at the
back and they play in a way that doesn't
make any sense it's because as a kid
they were put against too many of their
compatriots in competitive matches and
we're never taught actually how to play
and so I think it's more about finding a
teacher who is technique and obsessive
with technique I mean the coach I played
with invented the two-handed backhand on
tour he was the first person to ever use
it it's a guy named Mike Milken you know
he played Connors at Wimbledon so like
he all he cares about is are you hitting
the ball in the sort of like micrometer
sweet spot you know I can hit the
perfect shot he doesn't care he's just
looking at where I hit it like you know
and ultimately I think tennis is about
knowing your weaknesses
and I think my weaknesses for instance
our weaknesses that show up in other
aspects of my life you know so having
someone call me out on them a few times
a year actually helps me not just on the
tennis court but everywhere else what
are some of your weaknesses that
manifest elsewhere huh boy I would say
we want to trade weaknesses for two
hours but don't worry about this I won't
do this the entire interview he doesn't
understand why my margins are so small
he thinks that like the comfortable way
to play tennis is to give yourself two
inches of net clearance what is that oh
I thought your margins you mean the
space over the net with a door where it
God yeah and I mine is like two
millimeters because I just hit the ball
very hard and very flat for the lines
and he doesn't understand why everything
has to be so dangerous you know which is
the same note i get when i submit my
books to my editor why does everything
have to be so provocative why does
everything have to be so aggressively on
the edge of what's appropriate i mean so
it shows up you know all the time i
think the other two things are when I
get tense I tend not to finish my swing
which I think shows up in life also
which is when you're nervous or when
you're tense or when you go in with you
know feeling on your heels you don't let
the full expression of yourself through
you know so that's something that that I
think shows up and maybe also and this I
think is a common one whenever I'm going
through a string of unforced errors or
anything like that in tennis it's
because I'm hitting the ball too early
I'm reaching for it I'm not waiting for
it like it's not coming into my strike
zone I'm lurching forward for it right
set of you know holding on a little bit
do you do that with deal-making or
negotiating things like that where does
that where else is that show up I think
yeah I think sometimes it's it's a
tendency to want to jump in something
and say yes to everything and what I'm
lucky to have sort of the greatest agent
ever who really enough is a lot younger
than me who basically doesn't let me say
yes anything you know he's just like
wait hang on
like you know and it's it's sort of a
start with no and then just out
and then build from there yeah and also
just he's like it's not just saying yes
it's like you have to wait until
something actually excites you you know
so yeah well as another friend of mine
Derek Siver's entrepreneur would say
it's either a hell yes or - no nothing
in between and that's how he makes his
binary decisions but you brought up
something that I really want to
underscore for people who haven't
experienced it perhaps or who haven't
utilized it enough and this is a lesson
that I revisit quite a lot and sometimes
forget and that is we talk a lot about
of or state in general US culture talks
a lot about mind over body and and so on
but you can use body over mind in so
much as the Sports Arena the gym the
tennis court can be used like you said
as a way of surfacing and working on
weaknesses that then transfer to other
areas
and I have found that - to be the case
which is one of the many reasons that
when my exercise regimen is consistently
OnPoint everything else improves or is
easier so that is that's something that
I'm focusing a lot on right now all
right let's look let's dig into some of
those other stuff ah where do you even
begin I've so many notes in front of me
I will start with we talked about tennis
I want to talk about Walt Disney and
Disney so you are apparently obsessed
with Disney Disney World
let's talk about it why don't you just
try I'll just let the door I'll let the
door open and we can go from there well
I don't know if it was by choice I think
what happened was we didn't have TV
growing up we didn't have cable internet
any of these things that would go at
your parents - growing up my dad was in
real estate and my mom you know was a
very young mom you know she had three
kids by 23 Wow
you know was a lot going on so um she
she was trying to figure out how to like
raise three kids you know and back then
you know you had your VCR and your TV
that played a couple channels and that
was it so
we used to complain a lot to them that
we had nothing to watch we didn't have a
Nintendo we didn't have anything and so
my grandparents finally relented and
came home with the entire Disney
animated collection on VHS which was
like I think 27 movies or something like
that and that is all I watched from what
from age maybe six or seven until 15
that was all that was in the house so
like that was our only source of
entertainment and so I think Disney at
some level infected every cell of my
brain and it became for good or for good
or bad sort of an essential part of how
I thought about the world and it was
only later on you know once I got to
college I took a class on sort of a
famous class at Harvard on fairy tales
taught by a professor named Maria Tatar
who has become sort of like you know the
the most famous expert on fairy tales in
the world and she exposed me to the
original Grimm stories which are
horrific and dark and insane and half
the time the evil character wins and
half the time the good character wins
and I think that gap between the Disney
stories I grew up with and I took so
seriously and the real fairy tales is
where the school forgetting evil started
because the question that kept sticking
in my head is why did kids 200 years ago
grew up with stories where the heroes
didn't always win
where the hero died a horrible death if
they made a mistake and we got these
very sanitized versions of the story
where the hero always wins even if the
hero is not particularly smart you know
you look at the Little Mermaid you look
at the Lion King
Ariel should die brutally in that movie
because she's an idiot a complete idiot
I mean the number of mistakes she makes
in that movie doesn't make any sense so
then to read The Little Mermaid the
original where she dies at the end
suddenly made sense right and I think
that's where I started thinking okay how
do we get kids in in our world to get
the real stories how do you get them to
start reading something we're good me
more in balance where would actually
mean something again you know and I
think all of that stuff and then the
arrival of Potter
you know my knowledge of Disney that all
sort of played into what the school
forget evil ultimately became which are
sort of a mix of all of that with an
attempt to give fairytales back to
children and sort of make them really
think about what good and evil is so I
remember reading the original Hansel and
Gretel stories a few variations and
there's an illustrated version people
can check out if they want they should
treat it before their kids read it yeah
which I think Neil Gaiman played a part
in which really underscores how brutal
if you know of these stories were and I
let have use ice I've thought a lot
about Disney in the last few years but
I've thought about Disney more so in the
capacity of Walt Disney and there is a
fantastic Walt Disney Museum here in San
Francisco which I'm dying to call it's
so good something so good and it looks
at Walt Disney's a thinker Walt Disney
the Imagineer etcetera but also Walt
Disney that the technology innovator
yeah but I said glenn back of all people
has a book and he carried it with him
for some period of time and my
understanding is that it inspired disney
world's the garden cities of tomorrow
well I've read that book you have my sir
as Annie's or George Howard have you
have you been to Disney World
40 times I you know like I said Disney
was somebody that I admired so much that
I came to a point where once you started
admiring someone and studying them you
start to see their flaws and that's
where you start to see the seeds of your
own career because I think once you have
an idol and you studied them long enough
and you realize their weaknesses you
think oh wait I can I can come in here
with my own voice and do something
totally different that's going to
ultimately you know be be its own thing
and so I studied all that stuff because
I was fascinated the most important
thing that I was fascinated about with
Disney is his desire to create his own
city he was obsessed with this idea of
creating his own
not just you know Walt Disney World
amusement park he wanted his own model
community that the rest of the world
would then adopt that's what Epcot was
supposed to be you know it never ended
up happening and then you know for
whatever reason they abandoned it after
his death but I think you know once I'm
done with school friggin evil I'm dying
to do another series about the sort of
analogous to this idea of what the
perfect City of the future looks like
you bring up something that I'd like to
add to which is the benefit in a way of
heroes with clay feet and then so this
people have probably heard the
recommendation never meet your heroes
and that is said because of the fear and
the reality that often times when you
meet the people you most admire they
disappoint you in some way there is some
type of flaw there's some type of
weakness and it's the the frame to have
I think that is more enabling is the one
that you just described and that is you
shouldn't be well actually - you're
allowed to be disappointed you can be
disappointed but even if you feel
disappointed in some way everyone is
flawed and that should just encourage
you because it humanizes them you
realize ok they're not some infallible
metaphorically some entrepreneur or fill
in the blank who is hitting every foul
shot a hundred times out of a hundred
like no they have real weaknesses and
that then like you said opens the door
to the possibility that you could do
something of that magnitude so I find it
really encouraging in a way when I when
I explore the weaknesses of people that
I really really admire so in any case I
appreciate you making in making that
point you know the paradox of heroes
what is what is one of your if you have
one favorite failures because I think a
lot of people listening will think of
themselves good god all right so this
guy just seems to be a savant and
everything I can't I don't have those
attributes so let's let's talk about
some failure
do you have a favorite failure meaning a
failure that in retrospect really
planted the seeds of later success you
know I think one small one and one big
one
which was I had sort of tested school
frigging evil at film school in a
three-page treatment of the story and
the professor was this ultra jockey
you're talking patriarchal culture you
know entrenching kind of guy and I
submitted it and I went in to talk to
him at office hours and he goes so let's
talk about this story you wrote about an
Indian family and I said I didn't write
the Indian anything like he's like he's
like well which one he didn't have names
on them or he hadn't looked at the names
he was like well which one was yours and
then like he got distracted and was
talking about how his favorite one was
just one about fairy tales and he's like
whoever the girl that wrote it was like
she has a future that it uh and I said
that one's a mine and he his face just
totally changed and he couldn't get over
the idea that I had written it that like
you know that a boy had written that
story that star that had a female lead
character was that in the world of fairy
tales and he never sort of we never went
over it because he couldn't get over the
shock of it and there was something in
that moment that I think I took badly I
think I got ashamed of it and had I had
I reacted with a little more
self-confidence at 23 or 24 however I
old I was I would have taken the
positive comment he had given more than
the negative one to I mean but for some
reason I felt embarrassed by it so that
was something that I wish but it was an
important one because I think years
later when I came back to it with a
little more self esteem I was like out
of all the kids in the class he he liked
that one the best
why didn't I run with it that was like a
it was a serious idea the failure that
came that became sort of the the
cornerstone of my life happened after I
graduated at film school which was I
came out sort of the hot graduate
I got picked up by CAA office Crips and
anyone I don't know just to help
district on taa is one of the largest
talent agencies in the world if not the
largest but it did CAA wne William
Morris Endeavor there they're a handful
of these UTA out there but CAA is one of
one of the big motherships
and so they had you know they had picked
me up and descripted won a ton of stuff
and and it had won this you know big
grant and so I immediately got a studio
deal out of England to make the movie
and for I think was a six million dollar
budget which is ridiculous for a
graduate of or a movie that you wrote
for a movie I broke and so you know it
was it was sort of the almost like an
autobiographical story at some level
with some fantasy elements to it and so
I moved to London I spent a year and a
half prepping it doing all the work to
get it ready
you know we had crews set up we had a
great cast with everything set and it
was um you know right at a sort of bad
time in the industry financially and the
studio had had three or four flops in a
row and then there their big movie came
out and died and that was it they went
bankrupt six weeks before we were
starting shooting and I was in that was
in a year and a half I lost everything I
worked on you know worked for all those
years and I just didn't know what to do
and I remember going home and that's
when you know I started tutoring at all
that stuff but the biggest thing that
came out of there is I remember thinking
never again that's never going to happen
again I'm never going to work on
something for two years and put my life
and soul in it and not have it see the
light of day and that's when I realized
there has to be a way to control your IP
right there has to be a way to to
control the creative property so that
you know you can be in charge and that's
when I started thinking you know why
don't I go back to what I was always
meant to do which was fantasy and what
if I start with it as books first you
know what can I do
but even then I thought all right say I
write a book and it comes out and no one
reads it then we're back at square one
a lot of investigation into the kids
book industry this is where I found sort
of the magic secret which is I watched a
lot of authors going on tour
who wrote kids and teen books and if
you're a teen author you tour like an
adult author does you just go to
bookstores every night in different
cities and you meet your fans which you
know is great but if you don't have any
fans then there's no point right if you
write for kids 8 to 12
you don't go to bookstores instead they
send you to schools and you're put in
front of captive audiences anywhere from
two hundred to a thousand kids at a time
who you know don't know anything about
you and you get an hour to sell your
book three times a day to three
different schools and I thought okay
that I can do that if you if I write a
book good enough and you put me on tour
and I get to see 3,000 kids a day I can
tell and that's what got me got me going
I realized I could control the creative
and the business side of it and for
someone who lives their life one in
control because out I saw a career
waiting to happen
you know so it looks like an accident I
guess but I had I had sort of seen how
it could be done so I want to talk about
the selling and now that the more I hear
plus three three times a day a thousand
kids at a time I'm like why have I not
been choosing my genres more
intelligently because you can show up to
a gigantic book signing even if you've
had successful books and have 12 people
or two people I remember going to the UK
I've never so just as a contrast I've
never done what anyone would consider a
book tour because if after I remember
the before our work week came out and I
went to the UK and I expected to have
this fantastic launch and it did pretty
well but they wanted to rely on
everything that happened in the US and I
were going to my first book signing that
the publisher in the UK was handling and
I showed up and it was I don't remember
the exact name of the book store show of
its seven o'clock or eight o'clock at
night it's raining outside and literally
over two hours two people showed up one
percent it was just wandering
around and wanted to talk to me about
things anything that was unrelated to my
book and then one person who had already
bought the book somewhere else you know
nothing nothing brings you back to earth
like the British oh my god it was just
such a punch in the nuts and after that
I was like no more much like yourself
different context but I was like never
again ever ever in my life am I going to
have my head stuffed into the toilet
this hard from like an ego demolishing
standpoint but I digress that's my that
is my wall but I think it's important
because also I think at some point you
know all the principles that that you
believe in and that you know I've been
reading your books for years and and
immediately sensed a fellow soul you
know who is interested in the same
things all that stuff kids need and the
school friggin evil in a weird you know
sense is kind of a fictionalized
expression of all the stuff we're
talking about right it's everything you
know I believe in about the world and
and making your own destiny and planning
and not fitting in you know to society's
constructs and so you know people who
want to raise their kids with those
values I hope would then find you know
interest in the books but at the same
time I think you're due to write a kid's
version of yours because I just think
teenagers more than anything need it you
know in parents will buy it because they
know you so you know I think it's it's
coming why it might it might I've been
very intimidated and then I'm going to
come back to the coming out of college
and film school a quarter of a million
dollars in debt because I think that's
this important topic to dig into but
I've been very intimidated by in a very
I think good way some what I would call
and the genre names are confusing so
young adult fiction like carotene plus
okay thirteen plus when when I picked up
this is I don't know
two thousand
I actually know exactly when it was is
2005 because when I was doing my
walkabout around the world prior to the
4-hour workweek without doing all my
experiments I was in Panama and I was
reading His Dark Materials Philip
Pullman the golden compass and I had to
look up probably two or three words a
page to define them for myself I mean
nautical terms all sorts of stuff and I
remember wondering who the audience was
I'll blow your mind on that one Golden
Compass and Philip Pullman is not young
adult that's middle grade that's eight
to twelve what I consider myself a
pretty well-educated guy ya know he's in
he's intense and I think but he's part
of the whole Spectre that that I aspire
to as well which is if you look at
Narnia if you look at Golden Compass
even if you look at Potter middle-grade
is where you find the books that really
transcend to adults as well because is
never ending a story is would that be
considered middle yeah never ending
story as well I think the process that
was my favorite book growing up in for
three or four years in in elementary
school it's an amazing book and I think
the thing with a lot of young adult is
it's bear to gratify you know specific
teenage impulses from thirteen to
seventeen so it's very very sort of
melodramatic and romance based at times
you know and I think romance becomes
sort of an essential element of it where
is in middle grade you will often find
the more high fantasy you know that you
would also find an adult fiction which
is why I think often some of them the
best books that crossover things like
even like if you look at the best Neil
Gaiman like the graveyard book these are
these are middle grade books you know
like my favorite audio book of all time
probably is read by Neil Innes off it's
good and so you know that's that's also
why I love this genre because you know
it's Gorgon evil for instance the number
of adults and we have is insane do I
mean like there's no way we would sell
as much as we have sold and been able to
do what we have done without
adult readers what happens is the kids
get obsessed and then they give it to
their parents the parents read it and
then they start getting into it you know
the trick with the middle grade series
is that the first book has to be a
little younger that's why the first
Harry Potter boater they can grow into
the rest of the series it has to feel
like a kids book it has to sort of like
get the kids you know into it at some
level and then then you can start
getting deeper and deeper and deeper and
that's that's sort of how it's done
which is why even if you look at his
Dark Materials Golden Compass is is a
little bit easier but then two and three
are intent of well you mentioned
controlling your IP or intellectual
property so that you would be the master
of your fate more than you had been when
this this film evaporated in front of
you they were going to work on Golden
Compass one of my favorite books I don't
know one of the worst movies I've ever
seen in my life and I was so [ __ ]
enraged when I came out of that year I
was like how could you how could you I
was so upset that they tried to cram one
and a half or two of these gigantic
gorgeous books into ninety minutes or
whatever was it just it just infuriated
me how what have you done or how do you
think about protecting the integrity of
your work how do how do you go about
ensuring that is likely to be the case
because I'm not going to generalize but
yes I am I'm going to you you don't want
to take people's word for it in
Hollywood or anywhere else that's just
there are too many players or too many
cooks in the kitchen so what do you do
um well first thing I do is I have this
piece of paper and anytime I get on the
phone with anyone from LA I put it on my
wall and it says they are lying so I've
been doing that for about three years
and it really because they are lying
there they're saying whatever they need
to say the great thing about you know
Hollywood is once you figure out that it
is
is essentially the same kind of engine
as the political system designed to slow
things down designed to to make things
move as slowly as possible and we start
to realize that it's essentially like
working with Congress then for some
reason you start to accept it you know a
little more
I think the difference with me as I come
from that world right so like I'd gone
to film school I'd come out and been
involved with not just the movie that
you know had evaporated but I was
getting offered a lot of projects at
that time and so I had met a lot of
people so when it came to to you know
selling the rights to school for Knievel
I I got to pick who it was I didn't just
go with whoever gave you know the best
offer so I put together the producing
team which was you know Jane starts who
did L enchanted and tuck everlasting and
his and is known for putting together
the most faithful children's adaptations
of all classic books I mean that's her
her reputation and then put her together
with Joe Roth who is Alice in Wonderland
Maleficent you know Snow White my
Huntsman who's the big blockbuster
fairytale producer and sort of that
combination has been kind of the Magic
Bullet because a I got to make sure that
I wrote the first couple drafts of the
script to make sure that we were in the
right direction before I stepped off to
to keep working on the books and then it
made sure that we got on somebody who a
new screenwriter you know would put in
the studio's notes who also loved the
books which turned out to be right now -
David McGee who wrote Finding Neverland
Life of Pi and is doing the new Mary
Poppins for Disney and his daughters
love the book so you know I've been
reading every single draft of the script
I've been involved you know every step
of the way and it I as of now could not
be more faithful to the books that is
not to say that it will not end up being
the worst movie of all time that has
nothing to do with the series but you
know all you can do as an author is I
would say the advice would be hold on to
it until you put together the right team
yourself you don't just hand it over how
do you
whether it's through social engineering
and just and managing relationships in a
particular way how do you minimize the
likelihood of really stupid studio notes
getting forced into your script you know
I think that time has helped because of
social media
you know the fan base of the series is
getting bigger and bigger by the day and
I think they have learned from too many
things like golden compass or beautiful
creatures or or movies where the fans
revolted before it ever came out you
know and if you have to have the fans on
board because at the end of the day
they're the ones who are going to make
all the noise right you know like my
biggest goal when a real good knieval
was you know like look the way to make a
success is not necessarily that the most
readers straight off the bat but have
the most passionate ones you know so
will they become your marketing force
that's it it is and that's everything
and now you know to this day I spend at
least half an hour a day just doing fan
engagement to make sure that that the
people who love the books most you know
get as much access as possible whatever
you found most effective for that in
that half hour well it's tricky because
with eight to 12 hour core fan bases I
don't think it's really 8 to 12 it's
more like 10 to 15 but I think they are
not on social media so much right
they're not on Twitter they're not on
Instagram so we built an interactive
website that is I think the best of any
kid series in the world in terms of how
complex and how much it offers there's
18 moderated chat rooms there's like
games there's contests every week we
have a YouTube channel like there's so
much for them to do there and there's a
forum in the in the chat forums called
questions for so men and they can ask
the questions you know anytime they want
and I go on half an hour today and
answer them all got it got it so it's
centralized that you all right now each
little and lay this out so each year
looking at which met some specs your
player stats these aren't really stats
but he said you write a 500 700 page
book you tour 60 to 80 days so
a weekly YouTube show work on film
manage the business side of the school
for good and evil plus parenthetical
you're single at the moment which is
part-time job in and of itself New York
wait is not just a fart so it's like
death of your soul well you also have in
New York that it's a whole separate you
have the extra layer of paradox of
choice plan shopping issue there's a
there's a there's an abundance of riches
in some respects that makes it
challenging but what does your time
management look like what are the keys
to your time management what do you do
differently I know there's a lot of
questions but I'd love you just to
describe how you keep things in order
and prioritized well I think that there
are a few tricks
the big trick is one day a week is where
anything not essential happens so like
if I have to meet my agent or get a
haircut or like go you know do some
press thing or a radio interview or
something all of that happens on one day
so like everything gets shoved into
usually it's Tuesday Tuesday becomes the
like the funnel day for anything
miscellaneous yeah and so you know I
think that becomes the main day and then
I think for me it's all about segments
you know so like the the sort of core
anchors um of my day are I play tennis
in the morning at usually at 7:00 and I
work out with my trainer at 2:00 and
just having those two anchors makes
everything go so much smoother because
then I have a big block in the morning
from like 8:30 to 1 to like right and
and manage whatever else I have to and
then after I train from like 3:30 to
6:00 so I just think that becomes the
way I manage time is and also if you're
you're fueled by those two workouts you
come back like ready to go you know
you're just like in it and so I always
feel like I'm I'm operating on like pure
adrenaline at any given time and
operating very single-mindedly on
something and then I try to finish
working by 7:00 because I also think if
you work too late
it ruins the work the next day are there
any particular tools that you use to
help you manage all this um no it's this
is I've had fights with friends over
this who do think I should use a
calendar but my when we were growing up
my dad never used a calendar for his
business and he just wasn't into it he
just felt like he could keep everything
in his head and I don't know it's how he
grew up is how I grew up I never kept
track of my homework in school I never
wrote stuff down and so I don't have a
calendar which is so ridiculous to say
out loud but I don't have a calendar do
you now is that a reflection of just
having a prodigious memory or is it
morph is it a reflection of it being
more free-flowing do you wake up in the
morning knowing exactly what you're
going to do in those two major blocks of
time or I think that's it I think it's
because I know the anchors I know what's
happening it's the only thing I mean
obviously if I have to attend it like
I'm scheduling a trip for April or
something I'll have it written down
somewhere so let's let's it's an
exercise so today Tuesday today's your
odds-and-ends day yeah what does
tomorrow look like for you and what are
your key priorities if you can talk
about them yeah so tomorrow
okay so I'll get up at should get up
about 6:00 and then what do I do in the
morning so I'll meditate for about 15
minutes for type of meditation how do
you meditate
oh that's a that'll take us down a whole
rabbit hole yeah we'll come back to that
I'll bookmark that so 15 minutes of
meditation and then I start my day every
day with um I boil water and then I put
a towel over my head and I inhale steam
because for some reason it gets a sweat
going and somehow clears out my head I
don't know it's all like a thing I do
which which always works and it just
feels like you went to a sauna in your
house and then I'll eat grab a juice
from the place next door and then get
two 10s by 7:00 I'll get home by you
know 8:30 I'll be writing by 9:00 and
then write down working on revisions to
the first ten chapters of book 4 so I'll
do
that until about 1:00 then I'll eat then
I'll go meet my trainer and we train
firm about do you have a suit at lunch
that you have yeah so we were talking
about this before we came on I can't
cook and I just don't have time to think
about food so I have tried every meal
delivery service in New York City and I
use portable chef which is really good
which is basically like a customized
personal chef and they deliver all your
meals for the day today before got it so
everything's set for you so that one's
really great heart and belly is really
good and it's not it's not like blue
apron or somebody that where you have to
like have pots and minimal so you're you
heat it up and you're ready to go ready
to go so then yeah then I'll go train
with with trainer Dave as I call him
from 2:00 to about 3:30 and then from 4
to 2 6:30 or 7:00 is that second block
where right now it'll still be revising
but you know inevitably there's business
stuff too so I try to do that in a solid
hour as well so that's you and then
because I work in my my apartment most
of the time after 7:00 I leave I never
am at home after 7:00 I always go out or
do something see friends you know or go
on a bad date what are your what are
your favorite ways to wind down after a
day do you have an evening of people and
it's just you know the good thing about
having lived in New York for 15 years is
you know I've met so many cool people
and so you know I try to to go see a
show go see a movie
inevitably one of my friend I have a lot
of actor friends who are in anything so
now there's all there's always something
I premiering would give any pre-bid
rituals or anything that you do
typically before bed if I really want to
sleep well then I'll stop watching
anything by 10:00 even 9:30 because I
think I'd rather read then watch TV
because for some reason I just have a
very sort of like Oh
in spongy brain and if I watch TV too
close to bed that's what I'm going to
dream about what I'd rather not be
dreaming about you know The Real
Housewives of New York what do you what
are you reading at the moment or what's
the last book you found memorable you
know I've read this book three times now
and I keep trying to stop rereading it
but I think it's maybe the best book
I've ever read called a little life by
hanya yanagihara that came out a little
life a little life a little life it's
big I mean it's almost 700 pages but he
was nominated for the Pulitzer or
something and it's just incredible it's
it's about you know these four male
friends who grow up in New York City
together and it's sort of tracking their
life from when they're 20 to 60 and you
know for Pete for anybody who who loves
to have a bigger view of what life is
and look beyond sort of the again the
matrix of what life is supposed to look
like according to society that book will
just completely sort of ravage your
brain and then so I just think it I give
it to so many people and never once has
anyone come back to me and not said like
that changed my life you know I think
that might be the title of this podcast
episode ravaged ravaged ravaging your
brain for have explosive elements so a
few things the first is meditation one
type of meditation so or describe your
meditation so it's it's super simple
it's just going to sound a little crazy
to everyone because I've been doing this
for a long time like I remember I read
The Tao Te Ching when I was 23 or 24 and
going through a rough time after the
movie had collapsed or maybe it was a
little later a copy of it also six
inches from my left foot okay thanks I
remember reading it being like okay this
makes no sense
you know but you just keep reading it
again and again and slowly I started to
get the point of it which was thank God
I played tennis but it was saying the
same thing that I talked to you about
tennis earlier which is there should not
be any decisions it should be automatic
not automatic because there's something
in the way and the thing in your way is
bi the ego yourself consciousness so
every meditation I've done since then
and it's not about 10 years it's 15
minutes of trying to find the I that
sort of energy that makes up that
conscious will you know inside of me and
realizing that that's actually the place
that you do not want to operate from
that that is actually an illusion right
that's just a residual anger and
frustration and your inability to
control things in the world right so all
of my meditation is is recognizing the I
that you operate from and the world
tells you to operate from and realizing
that that's what you have to let go of
so when you sit down swimming you're
sitting are you then I'd like you to get
as concrete as you can and describe it
are you imagining the me so to speak in
parentheses behind the e sitting behind
the eyes and trying to visually or
graphically observe it or you are you
observing the words in your head as a
detached third party what are you doing
exactly it's more like trying to sense
the me right just sort of thinking okay
where is I where where is I am my body
right now right and trying to actually
imagine like your entire perception your
entire consciousness your everything
that's in your mind everything that's in
your body everything that's in your
thoughts right now is that I and
realizing that all of it is actually
wrong right and all of it is is energy
that you're holding that needs to be let
go of and what you really want is empty
space I think that's the line in the top
the thing that stuck with me the most is
you know why is there something when
there should be nothing right and it's
that whole idea of of the true happy
human is clear there shouldn't be
anything there and so that's what the
meditation is is trying to find baby I
the that Center of like me like you know
I can actually identify what the me is
and then realizing that that's that
needs to be like oh sure you're very
self-directed even lacking calendar so
you are I hope you have I hope
the studio has good key man insurance
view ah it's great going to leverage
though having this entire world you've
created inside your own head not without
its risks but you mentioned having a
trainer now uh in doing some of my
review before this you appear to train
exclusively with trainers I am almost
the opposite to your why that is wait
first tell me why you're the opposite I
am now it's not entirely it's changed a
bit in the last few years when I've I've
realized that there's certain types of
physical movement that I view as
recreation physical recreation not
primarily training so I'm not doing them
to lose body fat or fill in the blank
like AcroYoga acrobatic you look a
partner gymnastics that type of thing
and there are certain instances where
you need a technical coach tennis
gymnastic strength training in those
instances I will have a coach whether
I'm using video or otherwise but
training for me exercise has always been
my me time my meditative time to live in
the present moment and very often use
some type of cadence as um as I never
thought of it this way doing this up
until maybe a few years ago at a mantra
of sorts where I'm simply counting say
the seconds up seconds down a particular
lift or the number of repetitions and
that for me is my mental palate cleanser
for the day it's it's for a very long
time was my version in the sense of
meditation so I didn't want to banter
with someone else I didn't want to have
any type of sensory input from someone
else so that's why that's why I trained
by myself that is so in terms that still
the case with say weightlifting unless
it is a very technical skill and I'm
working with someone for say an Olympic
weightlifting movement where the penalty
of doing it incorrectly is so high and
you really require a separate set of
eyes to correct because what you think
you're doing is probably not what you're
at least in the beginning so that's
that's why I've always trained alone
end I like to train late so I love to
train at 9:00 10:00 11:00 p.m. that that
prefer a host of reasons but I have a
theory though I think that you might
instinctively be what I call a somatic
person which is like you when it comes
to anything in the body you want to push
yourself right so you won't let yourself
get away with incorrect form or or not
pushing yourself to the max you're not
doing were doubt that's true that is
true which is not me which is like
mentally when I'm working on a book or
something
I will die to make sure it's perfect
right to make sure that it's it's
exactly right but when I get to work out
my instinctive thing just because I grew
up then I grew up like you know the kid
who never thought he was ever going to
be strong who kids always made fun of
for being skinny so when it came to
lifting weights and things like that I
came in scared right and I always bailed
before it ever got heavy thinking like
you know I'm too weak to do this or
whatever I needed I need trainers to
push me beyond me at some level like I
need them to say this is what you're
doing and we're not getting out of it
you know right and I think because if it
was just me I don't know I would I don't
think it would be the same and I also
think like it lets me not have one is us
they have one moment of the day when I'm
not in charge which is nice right right
right right right this makes a lot of
sense you have this game this could lead
into all sorts of relationships that we
are injecting suspect madam how many
trainers have you worked with or is it
always the same person or handful of
people so I work with the same trainer
in in New York relative trainer Dave his
name's Dave stock still at CrossFit NYC
and I show him this game way not to get
a lot busier because he is an absolute
genius and I chose him the same way I
chose my agent which you're going to
laugh at but I chose them both by their
photo and I think it's because I spent
so much time casting movies that I'm
very good at at
when I see a photo or maybe I spent too
much time on tinder or something but
like I know when I see a photo that like
that's the person and so I remember
going through all the CrossFit gyms in
New York and like looking at photos and
I saw his I was like that's the right
guy and hold on I have to pause here so
what it can you is this purely
subconscious or is there some is what
you do a teachable skill do you think no
I think it's I think it's instinct it's
what it's I'm looking for with trainers
I was looking for like a softness kind
of like a kind eyes type of thing yeah
like an on bro bro right right yes I do
and and that's him he's the guy you go
to if you know you aren't like if he if
you're coming at weight training not
from like the brilliance place you know
what do you do when you're on the road
then I get a trainer every single city
every single day and it's a it's a bit
obsessive but how do you how do you find
them and how do you choose as are they
all photographed based no no so that's
too much more because that'd be
assistance she she knows um you know I
don't know she just she's pretty good at
knowing what to look for now because
I've been on enough tours and I'll be
like that one was great that one wasn't
that great so she started to get a sense
of like you know what I'm looking for
but I've worked with you know so many so
many different trainings trainers I
think what makes Dave so great is he
figured out very early on that it wasn't
just gonna be CrossFit that I needed but
he's mixed in a ton of GSD stuff which
is the gymnastic strength training a lot
of see health stuff which is like
exercises that also complement like
brain neurology like he's very good at
customizing based on your personality
what what your goal is like he knows not
to give me intense conditioning pieces
because I can out cardio anyone on the
planet yeah I mean it's just the way I
was born so he's focusing on my
weaknesses you know got us
alright well I'm not going to spend too
much time on trainers because so many
other places I want to dig quarters
million dollars in debt that's a [ __ ]
ton of money after undergrad and the MFA
so how did you and your family make the
decision to go so far into debt because
in the u.s. there's a very and I think
this is dangerous on a lot of levels and
anti at least in Silicon Valley there's
very romanticized anti College notion
yes and I do think that student debt can
be a a paralyzing problem for many
people how did you decide to go how did
you and your family decide to go that
far into debt and I don't know if it was
you or you and your family I don't know
how that was arranged well I think you
know at some level Indian families are a
lot like Jewish families and and other
sort of you know cultures that sort of
primacy on education where there is this
expectation that your family will pay
for school you know and my dad was going
through a hard time in in the 80s you
know because he was in real estate and
that's when when the market was tanking
and you know he took on a lot of debt
himself in order to pay for Harvard so I
don't think Harvard's where the main
source of debt came from main source of
that came from film school and you know
there was no way he was going to pay for
that or I was going to let it and so it
was just my decision really to basically
be like okay I was so deluded I guess
into thinking that like somehow I was
going to pay it back and I look at some
of the kids who came out of film school
and and are saddled with so much debt
now and I just don't know what you do
like I I was lucky enough to discover
tutoring which paid really really well
and I was lucky to get a ton of clients
and do really well at it so that's what
got me through and ultimately the book
deal helped me so you know sort of pay
the rest off but it is a gamble that is
not wise I think okay alright so now now
we're getting to the next question which
is what advice so much like college and
we've lost its luster for a lot of
people although I do generally think
that if you can get into a top-tier name
recognizable brand which sounds terrible
but whether it's undergrad or say MBA
then it can be worth it so I go and I
agree with me but the film the MFA Film
School is also one of those devices
topics where a lot of successful
filmmakers will say ah waste of time but
then there are many successful
filmmakers who come out of field school
aspiring filmmaker about to graduate
from undergrad or has already graduated
from undergrad and did decently well and
however we want to think about that
should I go to film school they love
film maybe they've done a few short
films in some elective classes in
college but their major was something
else
should I go to film school what do you
say to that person or what do you ask
them what's the conversation what would
I say now I would have such a specific
advice now which is only get go to film
school if you can get into USC that
would be my only only advice and the
reason why is the industry has changed
so much to a basically eliminate
independent film so that the only sort
of productive education you're going to
get in film school that will lead you to
you know a Hollywood career at some
level is to be in Southern California at
USC or you know maybe UCLA where you
have studio connections and are working
with studio professors and if you're
good enough you're going to get you know
you might get seen that's what I would
say because when I went to Columbia it
was in the you know heyday of the of
independent film at some level and so a
lot of the great things that happen to
me at Columbia were because I had access
to all the successful you know
independent directors and producers who
loved my work and therefore introduced
me to all these great people who all
those people now are having trouble
making films of course because there's
no outlet for them you know so they've
all gone to television or whatever so
film at some level if you want to work
in film we're talking working you know
in in the studio world which means you
got to be in LA you have tried to be at
one of those two to film schools but
otherwise I would say I don't think
there's a need for it I don't think I
don't think you need to go to film
school I think you just need to make
work yep this is the the USC reference
or I guess recommendation with caveat
makes me think of Stanford also in my
backyard here in the Bay Area yeah and
certainly as a compute as a competent
computer science major the demand for
for engineers so outstrip supply it's
it's just ludicrous but if you want to
be part of the Silicon Valley tech scene
and you're debating between different
undergrad options when Silicon Valley
and being based in Palo Alto where you
have all the venture capitalists
literally in the same town or right next
door gives you a can give you a huge leg
up
similarly depending on which facet of
the business you want to be part of it
was the one school that I didn't let my
because I helped so many kids with their
college applications over the years
Stanford was the one school I really
rarely kind of let them apply to why
that I I said it was too hard and she
was hard I said the problem with
Stanford is that you have to the college
application game is very simple
whichever school you apply to early
you better be fairly sure you have a
good shot at getting in because you know
when you apply early your chances of
getting in are much better but you have
to at least be in the game to get in
Stanford's
acceptance rate is so low and everybody
applying to Stanford is so good and so
smart that to get in takes an act of God
you better be like you know a real
miracle nature and so it was the one
school I recommended more often than not
I just said you are throwing away your
application because they don't take
anyone thank you it's harder than
Harvard it's Harvard then then Yale
Tauber than any school Stanford is to me
Stanford to the top school in the
country right
it's a great school it's a great school
up there they're business school
programs also outstanding I considered
it I had this I always thought I should
have gone to Stanford had I been able to
get in I mean I applied early to
Princeton got accepted ended up having a
very difficult time at Princeton always
thought you know I would have been much
better off having gone to a brown or a
Stanford yet cuz you're you're not at
Princeton is very square yeah and I
ended up I don't know if I've ever
talked about this publicly I ended up
but if you're familiar with a very weird
eating Club absolutely social structure
at Princeton but in effect for people
who aren't familiar with this you have
the the other street is a the street
that is lined with gigantic mansions and
that is where the partying happens
generally different welcome their
gigantic mansions they're all
stylistically different which is very
odd so you have kind of old tiny blue
blood New England rich mansion then
you'll have colonial style I've got a
Georgia Bell from old money mansion and
then it goes on and on it's a very odd
place and they're effectively co-ed
fraternities its easiest way to describe
it where you also eat meals and some of
these eating clubs it's just mind
blowing like Ivy for instance I believe
has an endowment so to speak that is
larger than some name-brand universities
in the United States it's just mind
blowing and I ended up trying to fit in
in some of these eating clubs and
getting very disillusioned and unhappy
and then joining an eating club called
Paris so Terrace to give you an idea had
a rainbow flag flying out front I am I
would have loved it I am not gay but
it's where all the it's basically like
your Tuesday
it's really it's where the odds and ends
yeah the people who didn't fit in
anywhere else ended up going and it was
the one thing I don't give any money to
Princeton for reasons that you guys come
to look up if you're you want to read
some practical thoughts on suicide and
essay that I wrote
and that'll give you an idea why I don't
give money Princeton I do give money to
terrorists because it saved me anyway
I'm not sure how we how I got all that
but I didn't fit in in any way at
Princeton was it important because I
think most of your listeners at some
level regardless of you know whether on
the outside they fit in or not I think
inside they don't which is why they're
looking for something different and
that's also why I wrote the books right
I felt like you know when I was growing
up there were no books for the odds and
ends right there were the hero always
want it was always a good looking guy
like even if you read Harry Potter like
he's always a good kid he always does
the right thing you know he's going to
win at the end because there's no
version of Potter where Harry ends up in
a pool of blood and Voldemort goes
kicking into the sunset you know I've
wanted to write a book that questioned
all those assumptions you know in some
level and said okay what about us what
about us weirdos who root for the
villains or us weirdos who don't think
evil is what evils made out to be and
that good often is not good and you know
all those sort of sort of big questions
so yeah that's why I think I've always
been attracted to your work and and
people like you at some levels because
that sort of questioning reality and
what the structure is is so important
and I think kids are helpless to do that
and and if we can train them not to
through books because that's our number
one medium to sort of get to them I
think it's a big deal which is why I
sort of take what I do like I said
- seriously probably well yeah I mean I
think that anyone is really good at what
they do really really good tends to have
a certain degree of pathological
obsession with with what they do if you
had to recommend books on writing or
books that would help someone's writing
is there is there a short list are there
any that come to mind let me think I
think and I'm not going to I'm not going
to make it
genre specific on purpose it could be it
could be anything for instance I'm a
nonfiction writer
at this point but bird by bird which is
written and LaMotta for fiction writers
really I found just
the best the cheapest therapy that money
could buy yeah yeah yeah that that one's
an amazing book I think you know I'm
less interested in books specifically
about writing because I think writing to
me is like breathing you write the way
you breathe everybody has their own way
of doing it everyone you know every true
writer has to write to stay alive
because that's how we that's how we live
you know that's that's our connection to
the sort of cosmos and so every writer
has their their specific process I don't
get so much out of writer books what I
do get books you know out of are two
things one books about creativity and
then you know sort of like creative
spirit and then documentaries about
creative process those are the two
things I sort of look at and so one of
my favorite books is called the spark
it's written by Cirque du Soleil
although very cool I love circus talent
and they never were called the spark
about where their ideas come from it's
very short you can read it in like 20
minutes
but it's fantastic and it gets to this
idea that so much of creativity is about
the fact that we try to control it right
but again it goes back to that idea of
the eye that I'm trying to get rid of
that if we just let go of this idea of
the conscious eye trying to control when
we work creativity and creatively that's
when the universe comes rushing through
and it so it's about almost making
yourself into a queer vessel and
accepting that that you know it's going
to come and I think one of the great
things about running a series is that
now that I'm on book 4 and I've settled
into a rhythm I start to trust myself
and when I trust myself is when the
great stuff happens because I'm not
monitoring I'm not judging and you're
not you're not editing when your general
editing and you're getting to it I'm
going to twist after twist where every
chapter is ending in a twist that like I
never predicted the characters doing
something I'd never had any idea they
would do and it's happening versus you
know the first couple books first three
books well it's you know every chapter
one twist or whatever now it's
constantly constantly constantly because
I'm allowing myself to take things in
new directions and along with the spark
we've got a cool documentary called
things called the fire within that
follows um eight people that try out for
Cirque du Soleil and it's sort of a so
it's kind of a wonderful Canadian
documentary about just you know people
passionate about their art and then the
other thing is I'm obsessed with
documentaries about creative process
specifically about fashion designers
because if you look at fashion it's
where you get 100% undiluted creativity
because it's on such a short cycle with
all the different fashion shows and so
it's also in a sense I mean purely
subjective which may head which adds to
the creativity by necessity in some
respects from yes and so you get to sort
of watch these madcap geniuses who
aren't constrained right because again
it's subjective so they can do whatever
they want because people have already
judged them to be geniuses at some level
you you get these amazing things so you
know things like do you are ni or
Valentino The Last Emperor or Lagerfeld
confidential Jenna if you depict one of
those three for a non fashion I'm the
most disheveled unfashionable person you
could possibly imagine which of those
three should I start with let me give
you another one then I think every one
that I think the best of them all is
called ballet 422 alright and it's on
Netflix
it's American Ballet Theatre has a
choreographic internship that's I think
the most prestigious choreographic award
a young person can win and people
compete I think from all over the world
for it I think and one the person who
won it one year was someone inside their
own company who was just sort of a
middling dancer in their company and who
was only 24 which I think the youngest
they've ever given it to and it tracks
his internship and his choreographic you
know process and when you meet him you
think he's a complete Yahoo right you
just think this he doesn't seem smart
he doesn't seem charismatic the guy's
name is Justin Peck you don't see why
they gave it to him you're just sort of
watching this movie thinking it's dull
you know watching like paint dry because
there's no variation
it's 100% watching this guy work
and about 15 or 20 minutes into it you
start to see him at work and you start
to realize slowly by slowly you're
watching a genius and you're watching
like a Mozart who was who is just gifted
with something that is absolutely
unrivaled and it's only like an hour in
ten minutes but it's the best hour and
ten minutes you overspend because you'll
get to see true genius in process
without any editorializing oh Cooney's
la before twenty two ballet for twenty
two it he said to become the best
choreographer in the world Wow
and he's young you know but you you get
to watch it happen I love it
yeah have you seen and it's it's a bit
of a
I use this in a loving way bumbling
documentary it doesn't take itself too
seriously but there are aspects of it
that I found so hilarious that I could I
could I came to I could charge through
it six days to air about out tell me
about it it's about the South Park team
putting together an episode from scratch
zero nothing and to shipping finished
product for air in six days I'll see
that I'd love after they went to the I
wanna city I'm still out out of la-la
land may go into the Emmys perhaps I'll
just say the Emmys they went to the
Emmys the Golden Globes or something in
women's dresses on acid and the only
they committed to each other that every
time they're interviewed on the red
carpet they could talk about anything
except for the dresses they couldn't
even make mention of the fact they were
dresses and they're on acid and then
they get back to the office and they're
like holy [ __ ] we only have six days to
ship a new episode better get to work on
that and then it's just crunch time
all-nighters insanity that's being
watched tonight very good put that like
that kind of stuff where you get to see
you know how the sausage is made is is
really the only type of documentary I
want to watch there's there's another
one that everybody should watch called
them theater of war about the making of
Mother Courage when they did it in
Central Park with Meryl Streep
and it's the only time Meryl Streep has
ever let anybody film her rehearsing
ever and she said she didn't want to do
it because she goes rehearsal looks like
bad acting and she goes I don't want to
see me you know do bad acting and then
she I thought did she change her mind
and thought maybe I'll be valuable and
to get to watch Meryl Streep's rehearsal
process you realize how much it is how
much of bad you know how much of writing
in the beginning how much of acting in
the beginning all of it is bad it's just
about doing all the bad stuff to get to
the good stuff you know for sure so yeah
the love another great one all right
I've been I've been making a list of
Docs to watch so now I was already on
this yesterday in my mind so now we have
a bunch of new ones to work on let me
let me jump to suppose what I always
call these rapid-fire questions but your
answers don't need to be short or rapid
what book or books have you given the
most as gifts to other people if you
have besides your own I would say a
little life for sure and then a book
called The Velvet rage The Velvet Ridge
another rage which is ostensibly about
you know if if you grow up a game man
like how to deal with it you know in the
world but I think it's more about modern
masculinity and about sort of what it
means to be a man in America and so even
for a heteronormative I think so I think
so I think you know the one thing a
little life in that book share in common
is an attempt to deconstruct what you
know the tenants of being a man are in
in this country because I think it
ultimately restricts emotional help you
know and so you know I think both those
books sort of give you a window into an
alternative and and yeah here's a if you
wanted a different shade of grey in a
book with all your spare time that you
might enjoy that a a number of my
friends male and female it's just found
extremely powerful is tribe by Sebastian
Junger and I'm doing it down it's I've
had it to be just a fantastic fantastic
and thought-provoking book that helps to
explain a lot of what we see in the
world and it might add just a different
lens through which to look at that as
well like I what is the what is the best
investment you've ever made and that
could be energy time money or any other
resource and I'll give you an example so
for instance Amelia Boone is a
three-time world's toughest mutter Jam
peon also power turning at Apple just a
killer cyborg and I asked her this
question and she said it was the
entrance fee for her first world's
toughest mutter or might have been her
first very toughest mutter in either
case the fee was
$450 which for her at the time was
actually stretch but if she hadn't if
she hadn't done that this entire other
career and life for her wouldn't have
opened does anything come in line for
you doesn't have to be the best but it
could be one of the best investments
this is so small but it made such a big
difference in my life which was that you
know I'd struggled with just like acne
for a lot of my teenage years and it was
something that like I couldn't get rid
of and I was an adult just having like
breakouts and stuff and I you know you
just it starts again on your head a
little bit you know that you could get
rid of it and so you try everything
that's the problem when when you're
built like you know me and a lot of your
listeners you try every effing thing and
so you're going to doctor after doctor
you're trying antibiotics you're trying
cream you're trying every kind of soap
and I just had had it like I just you
know gave up and so then I read this
story in The Times about a company that
had started it was called the ale ale +
biome I know I okay yes absolutely I
became one of their early adopters I was
one of the first ten people to try the
product could you describe for people
this this was my my year without soap or
something like that oh yes you've done
it oh I actually got a prototype sample
of a Oh biome way back in the day which
which is its own story - but can you
describe for people well I mean you
could take stab at I could take setup
but could you describe for people what
this is it's not antibacterial for sure
no it's the opposite tell me if I'm
wrong it as far as I know it's a
probiotic spray it's a spray that's just
pure water and you know bacteria that's
supposed to naturally reside in your
skin because they're there sort of
hypothesis was animals don't use soap
and you know don't really have skin
issues as regularly as humans do because
they have a certain kind of bacteria
that that sort of you know sort of
oxidizes all the bacteria and so they
created this bacteria
Spray that they said all you need to do
is throw out all yourself any cream
anything you've ever used in your entire
life and just use this you don't even
have to shower and you potentially would
be fine and so I was desperate I was
desperate and so I became one of their
first customers tried it within three
days my skin was clear and I've been
using it three and a half years they are
now called mother dirt they've changed
them no they did okay long termination
reaction coa o+ bio was not yeah it
doesn't roll off the tongue marketable
they they you know and they have they
have a shaving cream now that you can
use they have a shampoo that you can use
that that is sort of bacterial friendly
and man it made a difference let me tell
you that like it just changed everything
because you just did not forget the skin
thing i'm invested superficial but to
realize that the problems you were
chasing for 10 years or more than that
could be solved by your own body and by
something that was natural already that
theoretically like you don't even need
the mist at some level like if i don't
have it for a week i just don't use soap
and then my skin goes back to stays
completely fine you know definitely so
it was that that was a big shift and
it's called mother dirt now mother dirt
mother turcica if people want to read
the New York Times piece and hear times
does what I do which is confusing
sometimes that they'll use a different
headline online verses in the print
edition and then it makes things very
confusing for people but it's the I
would see my no soap no shampoo bacteria
rich hygiene experiment yes and I think
the I think the author's name is julius
scott discovers where she smells like
after twenty-eight soapless days it's
fascinating it's really really last
night yeah everyone everyone should be
on this product i said i feel like it's
a market that's that's going to explode
so what uh what other
tricks do you have like that give any
other any other expedient solutions to
come problems like that is anything so
you know just because I feel like
everyone's stress goes somewhere in
their body like some people get back
pain and that becomes their their big
thing you know sure with me it's usually
it was always skin until that was solved
and then I guess when I was younger it
was a stomach yeah one of my friends has
that his he always gets stomach issues
stomach issues also because I was on
antibiotics for the skin problems when I
was a teenager so that was something
that stuck around and again I did a lot
of research and realize that you know
you you can take a daily probiotic but
that probably won't be enough and so I
sort of cobbled together my own
probiotic therapy where I would buy two
or three bottles of different brands and
take those on tour when you're sleeping
it you know basically not sleeping
eating god knows what you know and it
completely off with them and just by
taking maybe like eight probiotic tail
tonight from you know whatever a
combination of different brands it
solved all my problems I can travel
anywhere in the world and as long as I'm
overdosing on probiotics with different
mixing up different brands through no
issues whatsoever it's to mix of the
different brands that I think is what
key right sauce and then the other thing
that helps just sleep just in terms
insomnia is if you have a an
aromatherapy diffuser one of those sort
of wood diffusers they can get off
Amazon for like twenty dollars and use
lavender oil and it it'll it'll dissolve
you out very very fast
lavender oil all right off to play
around with this I started using any
diffuser for the first time after I had
Nikolas McCarthy on the podcast who is a
one-armed or say more accurately
one-handed concert pianist and Shania
and he uses geranium oil when he's
composing he said it's the perfect
mixture of relaxation without sleepiness
its relaxation plus alertness for him so
I used geranium oil
for for a lot of my editing and writing
sessions when I did tools with Titans do
you use do you use the diffuser for
anything other than lavender oil or is
it I do I use but what's funny is this
is such a stupid answer but at the the
sort of food market I go to they have
this basket of 50% off oils of whatever
as in sold that week or whatever size
just by whatever is in there so I never
really keep track of what's in the
diffuser on any day it's just a
different stuff
welcome to my life but I'm willing to
see control over what aisles and the
diffusers when when you're traveling as
much as it sounds like you do 60 80 days
a year and I'm sure you have other non
tour related travel I do any tips for
minimizing onset of cold flu etc things
like that you know I think before I this
the same thing before I leave helps a
lot because it really does clear your
sinuses because that's where you can get
sinus infections and I think I was prone
to those you know a lot and I think when
I'm on tour and it's funny I read a book
about Steven Spielberg who apparently
does the same thing well we went every
wish oh I'm sorry
okay go ahead what are you shooting a
movie for him not to get sick which is
he drinks tea incessantly and herbal tea
just you know he's just constantly to
stay warm because you never know the
weather is you never know what the
situation is going to be but he's just
always downing hot tea of some herbal
variety and I think when I'm on tour
everywhere I go every time I get in the
car I get a hot tea every time I get to
a school I drink a hot so I'm drinking
like seven or eight cups a day do you
have a go-to hot here is it like the 50%
of it so you know if I if I can get to
Starbucks they've got the mint Majesty
which is really good I mean we should
preface this all by saying that I can't
drink caffeine because it makes me um
crazy you drink you drink alcohol or no
no I mean the glass of wine if it's been
a particularly horrific day but
otherwise not really I just think you
don't need it you don't need the the
enhancement or I'll take your handicap
one where the others is what I would say
and this is this is sad but I think
there's a happy lining to it which is
that I spent so long in my my 20s and
teens trying to get control of my brain
and trying to to make it a happy place
here I mean sure when I finally found
peace of mind and sort of the creative
space to be able to work in and now live
in a fairly I don't know just like
constant state of of goodness I don't
want to mess it up you know I get it
totally go I think that's that's where
where I am at the moment you know but
yeah what what topic would you speak
about if you had to give a TED talk on
something that you're not known for at
all so can't be can't can't be tutoring
can't be tennis can't be tenant can we
certainly can't be the writing that
you're doing it was might be on things
that make people laugh because I've done
all these studies because when when you
know you're writing you wanna you want
to get to the sense of what makes kids
laugh right because as horrific as the
school for good evil books are at times
they're quite dark they're also they're
also quite funny
and a lot of it is trying to find out
what makes kids laugh and so I would do
a TED talk I would I would hope on this
I read this book or this study about you
know these people who spent like ten
years trying to figure out what makes
people of all cultures last no matter
what like even if you go to the recesses
of the Amazon it'll make people laugh
they came up with four things and the
four things were nothing okay I'm going
to try not to die laughing like babies
number one is beating someone with a
kitchen utensil
ha ha ha got it good it's good to know
ok number two is falling down a short
flight of stairs
which apparently no matter where you are
it makes people laugh
number three is a swift fart delivered
inside I'm just going to say far it has
to be in there somewhere jazz wait I
like a swift fart delivered in silence
that could also know this might be the
name of my memoir and I use that I use
that in that chapter three the first
book and it's always mentioned is one of
the kids favorite well man I'm like of
course because it's one of the four
things and number four is number four
was such a shock and then it stayed with
me is adults dressed as twins what
adults dresses twins if you parade two
adults dressed in the same clothes in
front of a weird tribe in the middle of
the Amazon everyone will laugh alright I
would make a good dog so I just think I
think things like that like like what
connects everybody right what are the
common denominators I just think those
are important and so I'm trying to get
to the bottom of those because that's
what fairytales are also right that's at
the end of day school forget evil at
their core are our fairy tales so I'm
trying to get to the the essentialness
of and maybe this is why I'm so focused
on Zen and meditation and trying to
understand the world beyond the matrix
so trying to get to the bottom of like
what connects every kid what connects
every one of us you know before our
blank slates are filled definitely what
is what is the bad advice that you hear
given out often in your world and I'm
deliberately keeping that very very
broad not going to define your world for
you you can take it any way you want I
think when people say you know this
whole idea of like following your
passion right following what what you
think you were meant to do or following
what you love I don't always know is
going to lead you somewhere productive
because I think ultimately what you are
meant to do isn't necessarily what you
love it's it's what you're good at
it's what you are divinely meant to do
what you're good at
we think that's the better question what
do you what are you better at than
anyone else in the whole world what
would you what would you put yourself
against anyone else in the whole world
again you know at um I think that's
what's going to lead you somewhere
really good following you know because
what everybody wants to be you know a
professional athlete or movie star at
some level so I don't know following
what you love or your passion is
necessarily going to guide you to the
most fulfilling career well I think it's
also easier let's see easier in the
sense that there are more options for
taking something you are good at and and
molding it into something you can be
excited about hmm we're combining it
with other things that you are excited
about then starting with an undirected
passion and then trying to become good
at wherever that leads you oh you're
right you're right you're under pretend
right because if you're just following
the passion you don't have the whatever
it is the 10,000 hours that is that is
behind mastery to even begin right right
get going yeah if you could have one
gigantic billboard anywhere with
anything on it a short message no
advertising
what would you what would you put on it
a message to get out to the world I
think one of two things one is if I'm in
New York it would be Bacchus coming
you know I'm less than one other things
like them I meditate on a lot is just
what it would feel like to die that's
the other two Oh besides is that looking
for the me some days I just try to
imagine what it would feel like for
everything to just disappear first the
something of consciousness to become
nothing
so actually trying to experience that
and I think that has led me more towards
happiness than anything else in my life
is it so like trying to understand that
your life is short and it's going to end
and it can end at any minute so take
advantage right really really try to
make of your life everything you can you
know so that's the one thing and then
second one is um when I'm in Miami
because my parents have a beach house on
this island and it's so clear above that
you can see the sort of night sky with
the Stars and so if I was anywhere else
but New York I would just say look at
the Stars you can see stars in in New
York because every time you look up
there you realize the fact that there's
life on Earth it's such a weird freak
accident that should never have happened
and there is no meaning to life
necessarily in the larger cosmic scheme
of things it's just a fluke it's an
accident so enjoy it because the fact
that you know you got to have a life in
the first place compared to the sort of
infinity of the universe is pretty
remarkable I like that and it it
surprisingly echoes the thoughts of two
very disparate people have had on the
podcast also BJ Miller who's a
palliative care physician helps people
to die in hospice care and Edie Cooke
who is a memory champion and
entrepreneur from the UK both talked
about the stars in a similar way so I
think that is a profound place to start
to wrap up just a few more questions and
I'll certainly ask at the very end where
people can find you and so on but get
any any ask or request or suggestion for
the audience any any parting words or
recommendations suggestions please I
would just say that I think you know if
if these are sort of the principles that
you're interested in not just for
yourself but for for kids either your
own or somebody else's I think this this
book series will sort of lead those kids
in the right direction because it forces
them to question all their assumptions
about what good knieval are about what
they usually see in the world and about
you know what their life is going to
look like and it's about it's about
empower empowering kids when kids
usually don't feel empowered and usually
feel you know so so helpless so it lets
them reinterpret what heroes really
so I would just say you know give it to
a kid and see what the reaction is so
thank you so much for the time this has
been a blast and it would be great to
grab some mid majesty tea when I'm next
in New York or you're next in San
Francisco where can people find you
online learn more about you say hello on
social events one of the places to find
you where should they find you
besides tinder besides tinder if only
there were a search function last assess
uh let's I you know I think Twitter I
tend to post pretty regularly Instagram
as well and then we have our YouTube
channel which is called ever never TV
but that's you know mainly for for the
kids so Twitter and Instagram for the
adults ever never ever never TV for the
kids and also the school for good and
evil website is a treasure trove for you
know any kid under the age of 16 of just
even if they haven't read the books it's
just a great place to spend some time
because there's so many awesome
interactive features on there and
Twitter it's at soman chainani right
janani am i gonna rent chainani yes
Salman Chandani on Twitter and then
Instagram is filming see got it som a
and C well so thank you so much for
taking the time I've really enjoyed this
conversation and to everybody listening
you find links to everything the school
for good and evil of course everything
else all the books you've mentioned all
the docs you mentioned in the show notes
which can be found with show notes for
every other episode at 4-hour workweek
com forward slash podcast all spelled
out for our work week com forward slash
podcast and as always and until next
time thank you for listening
hey guys this is Tim again a few more
things before you take off number one
this is five bullet Friday do you want
to get a short email from me would you
enjoy getting a short email for me every
Friday that provides a little more soul
of fun before the weekends and 500
Friday is a very short email where I
share the coolest things I've found or
that I've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that I've discovered it could include
and gadgets and all sorts of weird [ __ ]
that I've somehow dug up in the the
world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I've read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in here or
email and you will get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by
audible which I've used for many many
years I absolutely love audiobooks and
they're one of my favorite ways to pass
the time when I travel I'm on the road
all the time and audible allows me to
consume many more books than I possibly
could otherwise I have two audio books
to recommend right off the bat the first
is perhaps my favorite audio book of all
time it's the only audio book I've
wanted to listen to twice in a row the
graveyard book by Neil Gaiman it's
amazing and you will thank there are a
few different versions
I like the version that Neil narrates
himself one of the most choosing voices
of all time the second book is
vagabonding by Ralph Hawks Pio tts which
had a huge impact on my life and form
the basis for a lot of what would later
become the 4-hour workweek so go to
audible.com for we're / Tim and you can
choose one of these two books or any of
many many other options that could be
books magazines and much more as a
listener of the Tim Ferriss show you can
also access a free 30-day trial just go
to audible.com forward slash him you
can't make more time but you can make
the most of it so turn your travel or
your commute into something more with a
free trial at laudable go to audible.com
forward slash Tim to start now and get
your free 30-day trial this episode is
brought to you by trunk club there are
two types of men out there you know who
you are guys who love shopping for
clothes for the short on time category a
and those of you who hate it category B
I am in the latter category my fashion
sense is also probably somewhere between
homeless
and confused with a dash of lazy added
in either way you can take art and I've
used trunk club now and have found so my
favorite pieces of clothing that make me
look a lot better than I'd be able to
handle on my own and there are many
reasons for that but you can get
clothing that fits perfectly and looks
amazing without ever stepping into a
store again thanks to trunk club and
they make it very very easy and the
clothing handpicked by a personal
stylist your own personal stylist all
you do is go to trunk club calm form
flush Tim type in your measurements
share your likes and dislikes they'll
pick your clothes from more than 80 top
brands and ship them right to your door
you keep what you like you send back
what you don't you don't like any of it
send it all that doesn't matter and
trunk club is not a subscription service
this is what appealed to me among many
other things I didn't want to constantly
be getting dinged by things or have to
deal with the headache of constantly
getting boxes it's not a subscription
service shipping is always free then you
have five days to try on the quotes so a
couple points here number one get
started today go to Trump Club calm for
flash Tim try it out you get premium
clothes expert advice no work no risk
that is a winning combo and I have found
some of my favorite espadrilles shoes
from them bright green I do like the
color green and they actually work I've
had so many compliments on these shoes
and more people ask me where I got them
than any other pair of shoes I've ever
had and more shirts I kept ended up
keeping about I would say three quarters
in my box which I did not expect to do
so go to trunk club comm forward slash
Tim and check it out
[Applause]